[Music]
days after director James Gunn was let
go from filming guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 some of the franchise's stars are
seemingly speaking out Chris Pratt
tweeted this message that many fans feel
is geared towards Gunn's dismissal quote
let every person be quick to listen slow
to speak slow to anger James 1:19 his
co-star Zoe Saldana also took to Twitter
writing it's been a challenging weekend
I'm not gonna lie I'm causing myself to
take everything in before I speak out of
turn I just want everyone to know I love
all members of my G OTG family always
will Dave Bautista has been the most
outspoken about keeping gun on the
franchise previously tweeting quote at
James gun is one of the most loving
caring good-natured people I have ever
met he's made mistakes we all have I'm
not okay with what's happening to him
James was fired from the Marvel
superhero flick after some controversial
tweets were resurfaced Walt Disney
Studios chairman Alan horn said in a
statement to et quote the offensive
attitudes and statements discovered on
James's Twitter feed are indefensible
and inconsistent with our studio's
values and we have severed our business
relationship with him
[Music]